- [Paige] Hello Grammarians, Hello David.
- [David] Hello Paige.
- [Paige] So today, we're gonna talk about
apostrophes and plurals.
We talked about this a little bit in our
Introduction to the Apostrophe video.
This is a very, very rare case,
where we use an apostrophe
to show that something is plural,
and it almost never happens,
but we will explain when it does.
- [David] Paige, when is the one time
in this immense and
wonderful galaxy of English
when the stars align
for it to be permissible
to pluralize something with an apostrophe?
- [Paige] That one time is
when you are pluralizing
a lower case letter.
If you're saying something
like, "You need to remember
" to always dot your i's,"
where you're talking about
the letter I, and there
are several of them,
you're gonna put an
apostrophe before the S.
- [David] OK, so that's to
prevent it from looking like is,
right, 'cause if we didn't
have that apostrophe in there,
it would just be the word is.
There's no way to tell I's
from the word is in that case.
- [Paige] Right, and
you need to remember to
always dot your is,
doesn't make any sense.
- [David] Right.
- [Paige] This apostrophe can look like
it's making the letter I possessive,
but it's really just there
to make it clear that
this is a plural I
and not is.
- [David] So this is the only case.
If it were upper case letters,
you wouldn't do this, right.
If you were saying David's capital As
look like trees.
It's less likely that
you're gonna gonna confuse
capital A, lower case S in
the middle of a sentence
for the word as.
- [Paige] Right, 'cause you
wouldn't just capitalize
the word as in the middle of a sentence.
- [David] Right.
So this is for only lower case letters,
the little ones, the inside voice.
(laughing)
Paige, that's it, right?
- [Paige] Yeah.
- [David] That's the only exception,
that's the only time you use apostrophes
to form the plural, no other time.
So if you're talking
about, doesn't matter,
if you're talking about CDs,
or DVDs,
or MP3s,
or whatever you kids are
listening to these days,
it doesn't matter, there's no need for an
apostrophe in any of these places.
- [Paige] Right, 'cause
that's pretty clear.
- [David] You just use a lower case S,
but if you're trying to talk about
multiple lower case letters,
then you use an apostrophe.
- [Paige] Yeah, so if
you're trying to figure out
how to make something
plural, and you're like,
"Do I use an apostrophe?"
No, unless it's a lower case letter.
You can learn anything.
- [David] David out.
- [Paige] Paige out.